in the simple prefabricated cabin in
hatai people gather for prayer to Mark
the end of month of Ramadan and the
beginning of the period of feast Aid
they live in a container city as their
houses were destroyed or damaged after
two earthquakes shook Southern turkey in
February
the Kaya family is among 350 others
living here
Jamal says he pulled the body of his son
from under Rubble 13 days after the
Quake struck being son Canada
sadness begins when you bury your own
child the Heartbreak never goes away
it's fate and patience is the only
remedy I beg God to take me not him
he says before the earthquakes all his
relatives and children used together at
his home this time only his grandson is
here
we lost one of our sons the other three
are scattered around the country my son
used to ask me to cook several dishes
now no one is here I cried in the
morning
children left traumatized by the
disaster find comfort in games months
later they are still unable to go to
school
the province of hatai was hit the
hardest by the disaster that claimed
more than 50 000 lives in 11 cities
people were forced to leave or shelter
in containers and camps
outside remains devastated by the
earthquakes that struck in February
people have come to the cemetery to
visit the graves of their loved ones
they lost to the disaster for them and
many others this year's Eid will be
marked by grief and mourning this area
of the cemetery has been left for those
who didn't survive the Quakes the dead
have been identified through
fingerprints and DNA matches and people
are searching the headstones to find
those they have lost and then tidy their
graves they know they can't bring them
back but some find solace in prayer see
Namco solo Al Jazeera hatai Southern
turkey